hi today I'd like to talk to you about
search previously we've talked about
ways to model uncertainty and also how
to make estimations about a particular
system when we were observing it from
the outside or when we don't have
perfect information at this point we've
almost got enough components to attempt
to make an autonomous system but at this
point we've also never haven't enabled
our autonomous systems to make complex
decisions for itself this is why we want
to be able to encode search or we want
to be able to enable a system to make an
evaluation of a succession of decisions
or a succession of actions when there
are multiple choices and possibly
multiple choices at every level so as a
consequence of being able to do search
our ultimate systems should be able to
complete a successive grouping of
actions and 6:01 we're going to be
searching state spaces and searching
state spaces borrows a lot of ideas from
state transition diagrams or what we
already know about state machines when
we're searching a state space we want to
know what states were searching what the
transitions between them are going to
look like or have access to the
transitions from a given state to all
the states that are its neighbors we're
going to want this start state state to
be specified so we know where to begin
we want a goal test which actually
specifies what we're looking for has a
consequence of the search or if we get
to a state and we want to know whether
or not we're done we use our goal test
and it could look at the output of the
state or actually just the state name
that sort of thing the other thing that
we're going to have while we're
searching is a legal action list the
search is that we're going to do today
you and I are going to be able to see
the entire state transition diagram at
once but if we're encoding how to search
on our robot our robot can't see the
entire state transition diagram at once
because if it could then it wouldn't
have to do search it would know how to
get there from here
therefore we give our system a legal
action list or all the actions that it
should attempt to do at a given state
it's entirely possible that there aren't
legal transitions at every state for
every legal action but it's good to have
an exhaustive list of things to try and
see
if they succeed or fail and as a
consequence what states you end up
visiting every time you try to do one of
these being able to do search is great
but we also want to be able to keep
track of search but keep track of where
we searched and how so that once we're
done searching we can actually execute
the best thing we're going to use a
search tree to keep track of where we've
been and how we got there search tree is
going to be comprised of notes it's
otherwise going to look like a just
directed acyclic graph and it's going to
have a lot of similarity to any
particular state transition diagram that
we end up searching but it's going to
have nodes instead of states nodes are
different nodes represent both the state
that you've expanded as a consequence of
being in that state you've visited as a
consequence of expanding its parent node
the parent node or the place that you
came from as a consequence of due
getting to that node and the transition
that you made in order to get there or
the action that happened that got you
from the parent node to the child node
keeping track of a list of nodes is
known as a path or it specifies where
you've been and how you've got there and
if you're at a given node you can
actually use the reference to the parent
node and the action to trace back from
whatever node you're at currently to its
parent node to its parent node to its
parent node and then finally get back to
the start state at that point you'll
know what path to take so the only thing
left to do is how do you figure out
which paths to follow first that's where
the agenda comes in the agenda is going
to eat the collection of all partial
paths you've ever created as a
consequence of expanding paths and then
expanding nodes and then putting its
child nodes on a partial path meant for
future expansion the order in which you
add and remove things to the agenda is
going to determine what your search tree
looks like that's a lot of information
at this point I'm going to go over an
example
we're gonna search the state-transition
diagram we're gonna start at a and our
goal test would be whether or not our
state was equal to e today we're going
to try two different kinds of basic
search one is referred to as
breadth-first search or BFS and one is
referred to as depth-first search or DFS
breadth-first search
refers to the idea that as you build
your search tree you're going to
exhaustively expand all the nodes at a
given level before advancing to the next
level or the all the given nodes at a
given depth before expanding to the next
step this means you're being very
thorough it also means that you're
guaranteed to find the shortest path
from your start node to the goal if it
exists depth-first search is the
opposite as a consequence of depth-first
search you're going to expand all the
nodes in a given branch as far down the
tree as you possibly can before
advancing to the next branch it takes up
a lot less space than breadth-first
search but it's not guaranteed to find
the optimal path another way to think
about these two types of search is that
if you're doing breadth-first search
then your agenda acts as a queue first
items in or first partial paths that you
discover are the first items out or the
first partial paths that you end up
expanding depth-first search is when the
agenda is used as a stack or the first
partial paths that you visit are the
first partial paths or the most recent
partial paths that you visited are going
to be the partial paths that you first
expend first in last out or last in
first out
let me walk through a couple iterations
on the state transition diagram and
hopefully it'll be clear what's going on
the first thing that happens is that you
end up visiting and expanding the start
node that's pretty straightforward
so the path a is going to be added to
both agendas and the node a is going to
be visited first on both search trees if
in the general sense I say that I'm
going to make a transition to states in
alphabetical order and that's the order
in which I'm going to add them to my
agenda that's going to be reflected in
when I write up here let's say that I'm
going to visit new nodes in alphabetical
order so nodes I would visit are a B or
B and C and I'm going to add a B and a C
to my agenda
here's where the difference between
breadth-first search and depth-first
search comes in in breadth-first search
because i'm following the convention
first-in first-out
if I place the partial path a B in my
agenda first then I'm going to expand B
as a consequence of the partial path a B
first so when I go to be I'm actually
going to expand B now I'm going to look
at the nodes that I can visit as a
consequence of expanding be the ones
that I can visit are C and D and I'm
going to add the partial paths a b c and
a b d to my agenda so AC I'm just going
to move to the front of the queue or the
agenda and I'm going to add ABC and abd
and I got there through B so I'm going
to add C and D here def first search
grabs from the opposite end of the
agenda so the first thing I'm going to
look at is AC I'm going to expand to see
look at the nodes that I can reach as a
consequence of expanding C and visit B
and D
a bee is still hanging out here I popped
off AC to use it in order to expand sees
children and I'm going to add ACB first
an ACD second
note that our search trees already
looked different and will actually end
up reaching the goal using one of these
search strategies first than the other
or you know as opposed to the other if I
go back to breadth-first search i'm
going to pop the partial path ac off the
front of my agenda i'm going to expand c
expanding c gets me B and D I'm going to
move over my existing partial paths and
add a CB and a CD
I've staggered these in order to
indicate that there are consequence of a
third iteration of breadth-first search
but they're actually considered to be at
the same depth since their parents are
considered to be at the same depth since
their parents are parents of the start
node that's the defining feature of
breadth-first search is the fact that
we're going to exhaustively search a
given depth in our search tree before
advancing to the next depth level if I
won't run one more iteration of
depth-first search again I'm popping
partial paths off this end of the agenda
I'm going to expand D D has one
transition available to a node and in
plain old fashioned breadth-first search
and depth-first search i run my goal
test when i visit a node so at this
point I would test whether or not he was
my goal test I would discover it's my
goal test I would my search would return
successfully and return the path found
so a B and a C B remain on the agenda I
popped off a CD in order to expand D and
I found this path
at this point I've concluded depth-first
search I'm going to do one more round of
breadth-first search to demonstrate an
important rule if I pop ABC off the
agenda and move all these over if I'm
looking at a b c and i look at the
children of C the two children of C are
B and D so the first partial path that I
would end up adding to the agenda as a
consequence of expanding C in this case
would be a b c b and it would look like
this you'll notice that we're going to
create an infinite loop and the there
are two basic rules of basic search that
i need to emphasize now to prevent you
from doing things like creating an
infinite loop if you look in the
textbook they're called how to not be
completely stupid if at any point you're
visiting a node in your partial path
that it already exists in your partial
path don't add it to that partial path
you'll prevent yourself from creating a
cycle because if you visit the same node
more than once you've actually done more
work than you need to the second rule
and it's not demonstrated well on this
state transition diagram but for
instance if I had two arrows from B to D
there's no particular reason to consider
both of these actions and if you have a
state transition diagram that allows
multiple transitions from one state to
another based on different actions then
you need to come up with some sort of
rule to decide between the two actions
that's the second rule of how to not be
completely stupid is if you have more
than one transition from one state to
another as a consequence of doing search
pick one
and come up with a rule to pick one this
covers basic search next week I'm going
to talk about dynamic programming costs
and heuristics